we just started and this is already a
mess and I make this less chaotic when I
ask inside my brain every day what's in
the background no one will ever know hi
my name is grace Helbig if you did not
know now you know your life is different
now I have something in my eyeball as
she said hey the biggest international
thing happening at the moment unless
something else has happened before I
upload this video are the Olympics day I
decided I'm going to make an Olympic
steamed cooking video for you I did
research for this video I know I
fulfilled what the Olympic rings mean
there are five interlocking Olympic
rings for each of different color
I don't many specifics why have you been
telling you about recent phenomenon in
specifics broad strokes
that's the swimming competition I think
I might be an Olympic gold medalist
here's the broad-strokes version the
five Olympic rings on the flag the
colors represent every color that is in
every flag of every country that is
represented at the Olympic Games and the
Five Rings themselves or present the
five continents years and years and
years and years ago in which athletes
came from to compete Neela Dix I say
continent correctly I'm saying continent
continent continent the continents in
which the five rings represent our
Africa Asia the Americas Europe and
Oceania ocean and ocean and ocean
Anakin's I wish God I wish I lived in
the country called ocean and again I do
it's in my brain there's no walls you're
welcome so today I wanted to make an
Olympic theme meal that encompassed some
of the most popular and/or stereotypical
foods of each of the continents that
compete in the game of Maxim nope that's
I am taking copious notes for today's
video and I still have no idea what I'm
going to do so I think I've found a food
or foods that best represents each
continent and we are going to put them
together into one dish that I'm calling
the
Olympic pop good luck probably not good
to have the word Olympic pop good luck
and or cow in the zone and or I'm full
tower and we're the tower of geez
I offered and or I think I've been Egypt
and or Statue of Liberty where's your
bathroom let's start making this meal
here we go
you can do it yes you can you can do it
but also maybe not oh you might be
wondering why I'm wearing a pajama shirt
for this meal I wanted to wear something
that I thought fully represented over
country because remember what language
we speak or where we live we all sleep
thank you thank you I'm gonna regret
this immediately first things first I
thought the best way to make an
all-encompassing global dish would be to
start with a base of pizza Michael
Phelps do you guys also hear
high-pitched ringing noise it's okay if
you don't totally fine if you don't one
of the first things I'm going to put on
my pizza is a very common African food
says the Internet to me and that is
couscous and this couscous cooks in five
minutes we'll see about that also I
don't know why this couscous is called
Near East not the Far East but it you're
neat I don't I'm gonna follow the
directions on this box and create
toasted pine nut
couscous in five minutes yeah right but
then again some of us look at a girl
it's four feet eight inches tall and we
say what can you do and then we see it
we go alright oh we're in the gold medal
at Foley artistry so we have Africa
heating up now we're going to move on to
Americas and when I say Americas I mean
North and South America collectively so
I have a little bit of all of it don't
judge me too soon hot dogs specifically
doctor dogs oh cool
I found them down there with your
expectations oh honey heat up this pan
this isn't what America looks like to
the rest of the world I don't know what
is that's doing something go heat up too
before I move on I have to let you know
that we will get more into the things
that represent Europe other than pizza
and one of those right now Russia I'm
looking at you
vodka wars so Oceania was one of the
bigger areas that I had question marks
about and once I research it I found
that it meant Australia New Zealand
Indonesia
so the dish that I'm using to represent
Oceania is shrimps on the barbie
my dog literally just walked out the
door I forgot to buy shrimps at the
grocery store a good thing I had this
rogue bag frozen shrimp in my freezer I
don't know when this was actually bought
this could possibly be two years old
that's enough this Dodger dogs look like
burn means my dogs barking at someone
and I can't go out and help you da Luz
please not now you're not going in a
compromising stage this is how your
mother makes money so real that our
shrimp I don't know just like chill Oh
our couscous water is couscous I'm going
to put one spice sac flavor in my sac is
a great name for an athlete dirt with a
knife and you just put this in and then
take your ring MIDI you let it stand for
five minutes
this is like that hot tub world divers
go into you after they dive a ShamWow
themself okay show was going on we're
still working on our Barbie shrimp I
need to melt butter and garlic together
and I just wanted to let you know that I
got European style butter I'm a human un
I'm humanely unfit to be around others
that goes in to cloves of minced garlic
okay
says to melt it over the stovetop I
translate that to microwave I think our
shrimp are thawed but they still have
these little tails on for I take the
tails off
oh yeah we are we have a elephant it
Australian chance for sports we have to
fill a couple of our wooden skewers in
water so that our shrimp don't get oh I
guess all our skewers are soaking it's
time to add another ingredient know that
most of the time we'll think about
America's you think about the USA which
is good about Canada but not this time
Canadian bacon Oh product of Canada so
let's go some bacon on this grill there
we go just a couple strips
that's like here one of those diver is
dive into the water you go to a basic
way to add our other ingredients to this
melted butter garlic thing a teaspoon of
garlic powder ish half a teaspoon onion
powder half a teaspoon cumin oh no three
tablespoons light brown sugar and 1
tablespoon Old Bay seasoning if you al
gonna get sexy in here is it just the
smoke from the bacon bread put our bacon
down on some paper towels you look great
and a skewer our shrimp took everything
in me not to want to make a bloomin
onion no didn't take everything in me
just took one part of me the part of me
that was like that's too much work I'm
literally bleeding
I literally ha OH - red pepper flake my
bad so we're going to paint one side of
our shrimp with our shrimp Barbie
mixture Barbie let's go party okay put
this down on the grill now let's cover
the other side of it you can't even see
this fire I'm take a look at what we got
going on there's our couscous I got some
shrimp happening there there's some dogs
back there our bacon dressing very long
skinny very American Dodger dog all
right we got the America we got Africa
we got Europe we got okie Aniyah they
don't Ganesha and my first thought for
Asia was right but the couscous kind of
is the same thing is right so when I
googled one of the most popular dishes
in all of Asia
satay came up meat on a stick I am beat
sorry vegans I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry deep-set
it 30 minutes to make [ __ ] why didn't I
do this
everything is fine we need two
tablespoons of lemon juice and two
tablespoons of fresh ginger grated okay
so wait to grate this food prep is such
a thing damn it out
hey shrimp dumber and go this to the
side a medium best goal was together
diamond juice ginger soy sauce okay oh
god there's so many seeds
my hands are clean ish tablespoon of soy
sauce we're just now I wanna get a
little bit oh my god my battery's dying
No 1 TSP fish sauce great teaspoon chili
paste
yes I do have chili garlic it's a mix
this together than at the bees okay we
switched the battery I cut the strip
stick into one-inch things insert all
stripped ropes now you are hilarious
meanwhile we're going to just rinse this
out oh we're going to put our beef in
this plastic bag great and then we're
gonna marinate on it so that the more
whiskey business yeah well we're going
to preheat our oven cuz we're going to
start with this pizza together make this
goddamned peanut sauce 4 tablespoons of
creamy peanut butter and we're going to
use our peanut sauce for the whole pizza
so I'm just gonna go nuts
a tablespoon soy sauce okay Davis minute
lemon juice Shh I just used all the
melon juice oh can I substitute sorry
I'm gonna try and find a plan okay
I've seen a bunch of recipes with a
bunch of different [ __ ] in it so we're
just going to go for human I'm sure I'll
be really cool about it sesame oil now I
don't test me oil I have to separate
peanut sauces already created in my
refrigerator great I just take an hour
and a half Jesus Christ I gotta watch
gymnastics a car babe we go skewer them
three minutes on each side gonna add
some lime juice to our peanuts house
because this bit why the shots not now
right put this in microwave because I
don't use a lol let's start putting
together to find it European pizza
crusts are crispy we should have been
the last thing we cooked take some of
our peanut sauce just a little bit now
our take our blue bread alone on top
I gotta have sauce cheese now it's time
for
chopping I'm taking this hotdog cut it
up this is the American Way
my Canadian bacon going shrimp on the
barbie just like the Olympics a lot of
meat
seems good I'm gonna drizzle a little
bit more peanut sauce on top and I'm
finally we're going to finish with our
beef skewers just gonna kind of cut them
out out out at shoot okay and then your
piece of beef and just spread them on
top because I oh it looks done but it's
not we're gonna put me up this was so
done with you grace we put everything in
the oven I've grabbed the one thing to
find every country together cheese
cheddar cheese great how long you cook
for a window I'm gonna let this cook for
a mysterious amount of minutes and then
we'll be right back look at it that
looks like the Olympics that I've ever
seen out out I just like getting to the
Olympics the journey to get there takes
much harder work unexpected twists and
turns and watch longer than the final
outcome I should let this rest for a
while I know this is our oh no that's
okay this is our with the fizzes this is
our limp at vimla Olympic Cox's lot you
create a name for this how it's so how
this is going to hurt here we go
oh I'm in Dominique all you just carry
stuff my mouth I Dominique mochi I need
you rich if you guys enjoyed this video
or did not enjoy this video please
subscribe to me you know there you are
buddy they subscribe to my youtube
channel let me know what you're watching
at the Olympics and if you decide to
make this like every Olympic athlete
commits make sure you put hours and
hours and hours aside where you will not
see your friends your family you'll hate
yourself you'll love your actions but
nan k success
I'm nothing it under clothes I don't
know did you guys know that I did
competitive gymnastics until I was in
eighth grade or seventh grade and then
like I just got tall and everything I
hurt I'm most difficult yeah
and or oh can I do a bucco